[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've new wheels
the pre-celebration for the big day huh
I make your partner baby Oh give it up
worldwide sports management's newest
partner boys club every days you don't
connect well with men just stay in your
lane I don't trust women who don't get
dudes like I don't trust a man with no
eyebrows are too many keys I know
someone you should talk to
I can help you commit with me why don't
we have some tea this is nice like dirt
oh that's just jasmine tea if you don't
count the Wiis nobility no crack
[Music]
[Applause]
oh hello welcome back miss Davis
thank God this one didn't die on me
starting today no more drinking at work
hey that's too much information that's
anything I feel we here after last night
yeah that's what happens when tequila
meets and desperation okay stop saying
things you shouldn't be saying to your
boss holy crap can you hear my inner
thoughts
I can only hear mean stuff that cloud
you're walking through that's my focus I
thought black people stopped when you
have to get out where would you complain
about men trying to keep you down do we
have any meetings on the books nothing
yet except the private poker game
tonight this is not a curse after 10
days
the lady which is doing at the big boys
table huh so quite I'm bluffin ease
falls I'm missing Real Housewives check
finally has a winning hand why am I
thinking in the third person I smell
toast my happiness true wait I have
toast in my pocket
[Music]
- great
little lady is she doing it the big boys
table huh I'm missing Real Housewife I
smell toast have a stroke wait I have
chosen my pocket who come on somebody
says I love shark tank statistically
I've got 12 outs to streets to come
pretzels are delicious man look at that
ass I should tap that before the wedding
or a free press and all the ladies
whatever why would I waste a second on
her when I got you standing right here
in front of me
this boy's body the Shinto shrine okay I
think breakfast he ever has this may be
my patent smoothie oh man not the
smoothie man
you took my kale she has seed coconut
juice avocados you know I mean this
boy's body look at his legs on top their
fish oils Megan on sometimes fives and
sixes only depends on what I've pumpkin
seeds sunflower seeds some pistachios
sometime born out whatever it is that's
healthy no wait a minute I put more
stuff in sometime I Jamie's little soy
sauce
sauce okay did I have more cheese on top
of that I care about this hip boy you
want to know how to connect with me
right well I can help you open your
inner report or so let's just have some
tea and I can read you just take a sip
relax no smell
get it down sit up that's just jasmine
tea if you don't count the weed in the
peony okay crack I was just kidding
either with the balls they attached to
me why are her eyes closed if I'm ugly
damn my eyes open but she look crazy as
hell oh [ __ ]
yes I do
how's that bills but nom know I was like
you and I and you know I have a thing
that I wanted girl feel that SS ran a
half a marathon need some electrolytes
you know I don't smoke nothing after sex
arm give me some gay yesterday no I got
flavors the bride and groom have written
their own vows
I'm so sorry I'm sorry I have something
I gotta say what are you doing I've been
given a gift
I can hear men's thoughts right now
because of my gift James I know you are
not worthy of my friend Mari what are
you talking about he slept with your
cousin Gaby last name that never
happened that never never happen I am so
sorry Mari he said you want a break
everybody line right
I feel weird after last night yeah
that's what happens when tequila meets
and desperation
okay stop doing that stop doing what
talking without moving your mouth and
saying things you shouldn't be thanks to
your boss I swear on my life I would
never say anything disrespectful or
inappropriate to you ever which is more
than I can say for you right there
you just did take more than I can say
for you I heard you sing I didn't say it
fully crap can you hear my inner
thoughts
[Music]
you